the black king will move and Advance  between the king and Knight this will  end in a draw and let's go back to the  players we'll see a result we'll see  Magnus confirmed as the winner of the  tournament if Prague repeats moves  anything else for white and you're just  two Rooks down so I don't think you can  carry on safely will we see a  celebration for Magnus do you think  after this game  we'll see a smile yeah I have a feeling  he won't celebrate till at the end of  tomorrow when the tournament's done but  now it's pretty much confirmed if white  brings his Knight back to give a check  the position will repeat itself for a  third time  there we go it's a draw Magnus beats  Prague Magnus Carlsen is the winner of  this match he is the winner  of the tour finals what a tournament  it's been for the world number one he's  oh  unbeaten he's played some fantastic  chess and he finishes off an incredible  start